whether you're cooking the turkey
tomorrow or just simply showing up
Raymond and Laura have got you covered
with some Thanksgiving do's and dont's
take a listen to this I can tell you
everything you need to know but okay
I've studied it researched it and I've
lived through the trauma of bad things
all right Raymond of all trades
okay what's the biggest don't for thanks
girl here's one thing don't do don't
create a family wide fast where you
deprive the people in the family of food
all day long until you're ready I'm just
telling you ladies and I love you all
men do not like to go all day without
eating if they get angry they have you
dare rage I do I admit it and that
causes all kinds of problems at the
table so if you want to sell in very
quiet meal because everybody's caught
scarfing down the food do that but my
advice put finger sandwiches out let the
meat around 1 o'clock 2 o'clock so
they're not angry bears come makes
finger sandwiches still that's something
my grandmother made you can buy them
when you're cooking at 6 or 7 courses
buying finger sandwiches are easy that's
an easy thing to do my mother was always
just left nuts and stuff out M&M that's
cool your family of squirrels yeah that
big old-fashioned cracker and crack the
nut Oh what would get into a 40 right
giving you a list of it break out the
nut cracker kids my mother god bless her
would start playing the Polish Christmas
carols
now I actually love them but it's a kid
of like we have some like rocking her up
no Brenda Lee at your home she was so
great but if you like this dad like oh
like a Polish funeral those themes are a
little dreary I've been okay don't cook
a turkey if you don't know how to cook
the turkey a disaster can ensue and you
had you were too quick don't um don't
try a recipe on Thanksgiving or the
first time Oh terrible thing terrible
right idea of making an apple cranberry
pie for Thanksgiving and my mother was a
is she was unbelievable cook but
especially a pie she was like Marie
Callender there is no way to ever a
replicate what my mother did I can still
take the pot I made this thing and I
thought I was I'm rolling it out rolling
it out rolling up you thing you don't
want our ball you never want to overcook
anything particularly the bird watch see
board it through those and the other
thing you shouldn't do it I didn't even
finish my story well you can finish that
in the book you don't want to do is to
create moisture people think put more
grease or olive oil in the pan that
you're cooking the burden this never
works
[Music]
[Music]
it's oh my god
it wasn't I've never seen anything quite
that bad but some of these these
kitchens just go up in flames well my
mother used to always say and I always
think of her these times a year I miss
her a lot is that people eat fast and
then they just leave the table and
there's just this I've slaved all day
with my crippled thing the other thing I
would recommend people do how we get to
this next clip make sure you spread the
pain at your holiday table that means
separate the disgruntled members of the
family who might fight put them far away
from one another that way blood on the
knife across the country across the
country is even better way to separate
all you thinking you're way ahead and if
you happen to be a volunteer at the
Macy's Thanksgiving Day Parade make sure
you have a workout routine or wear heavy
weights otherwise this can lead to
catastrophe this is
I was a fan of Barney they completely
1x4 one balloon had to go away that's
the one I slammed into a light bulb
because the women couldn't hold him down
and they're sliding across 7th Avenue it
is it is a lot of work for people to put
on a Thanksgiving dinner ends there are
a lot of people just like you know I'm
exhausted because a lot of people narcs
and they just they like I'd rather have
someone else do the cookie a lot of
people do go out